>>> NEW THIS MORNINGGABBY
PETITO'S FAMILY IS SUING THE
MOAB CITY POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR
$50 MILLION.
YOU MAY RECALL THAT OFFICERS
PULLED OVER PETITO AND HER
FIANCE BRIAN LAUNDRIE AFTER A
WITNESS SAW THEM FIGHTING.
THE PAIR APPARENTLY WENT ON
THEIR WAY AND PETITO'S BODY WAS
FOUND A MONTH LATER.
CNN'S JEAN CASAREZ HAS THE
DETAILS.
>> Reporter: A CROSS-COUNTRY
ROAD TRIP THAT ENDED IN TRAGEDY
MAY SOON BE THE SUBJECT OF A
LAWSUIT.
A ATTORNEY FOR GABBY PETITO'S
FAMILY ANNOUNCED THEIR INTENTION
TO SUE THE MOAB CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN UTAH.
>> GABBY'S PARENTS ARE BRINGING
THIS LAWSUIT TO HONOR GABBY'S
LEGACY BY WORKING TO SAVE THE
LIVES OF VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE, THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES AND THE WORLD.
>> Reporter: PETIPETITO'S FAMIL
SEEKING $50 MILLION IN DAMAGES
AND NEGLIGENCE AND WRONGFUL ACTS
THAT THE FAMILY SAYS CONTRIBUTED
TO GABBY'S DEATH.
THE NOTICE NAMES NOT ONLY THE
MOAB POLICE DEPARTMENT,
INCLUDING THE CHIEF, FORMER
ASSISTANT CHIEF AND THE TWO
OFFICERS THAT INTERACTED WITH
PETITO AND HER FIANCE BRIAN
LAU
LAUNDRIE.
>> THIS IS JUST BRINGING BACK --
SORRY.
THIS IS WHAT I WAS TODAY, WE'RE
GOING TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN,
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO THE
DOCUMENT, PETITO'S FAMILY SAID
THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS OFFICERS
NEGLIGENTLY FAILED TO UNDERSTAND
AND ENFORCE UTAH STATE LAWS.
INVESTIGATE LAUNDRIE'S, QUOTE,
SELF-EVIDENTLY FELT CLAIMS
PROPERLY TRAIN THEIR OFFICERS ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INCIDENT,
PROPERLY ASSESS THE
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING, QUOTE,
TO IDENTIFY BRIAN AS THE TRUE
PRIMARY AGGRESSOR.
CNN REACHED OUT TO THE CITY OF
MOAB ON MONDAY FOR COMMENT BUT A
CITY SPOKESPERSON TOLD CNN THAT
THE CITY DOES NOT, QUOTE, THE
CITY DOES NOT COMMENT ON PENDING
LITIGATION.
PETITO AND LAUNDRIE LEFT ON
AUGUST THEY WERE TRAVELING MOAB,
A 911 CALLER REPORTED SEEING A
MAN, QUOTE, SLAPPING A GIRL.
BODY CAM VIDEO SHOWING ADMITTING
THEY HAD A FIGHT, SAYING SHE
LAPPED HIM FIRST.
ACCORDING TO THE POLICE REPORT,
OFFICERS SUGGESTED THE COUPLE
SEPARATE FOR THE NIGHT AND NO
CHARGES WERE FILED.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATORS FOUND
THAT MOAB CITY POLICE OFFICERS
MADE, QUOTE, SEVERAL
UNINTENTIONAL MISTAKES IN A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESPONSE.
AND CALLED FOR MORE TRAINING FOR
OFFICERS.
>> WE DO AGREE WITH THE FINDINGS
OF THE INVESTIGATIVE REPORT THAT
THE OFFICERS FAILED TO RECOGNIZE
THE SERIOUS DANGER THAT SHE WAS
IN.
AND FAILED TO INVESTIGATE FULLY
AND PROPERLY, THEY DID NOT HAVE
THE TRAINING THAT THEY NEEDED TO
RECOGNIZE THE CLEAR SIGNS THAT
WERE EVIDENT THAT MORNING.
THAT GABBY WAS A VICTIM.
AND THAT SHE WAS IN SERIOUS NEED
OF IMMEDIATE HELP.
>> Reporter: THE INVESTIGATOR
SAID HE COULD NOT SAY WHETHER A
DIFFERENT RESPONSE TO HAVE
PREVENTED PETITO'S DEATH.
AND THE LEGAL FILING CITES
SEVERAL SPECIFIC EXAMPLES.
GABBY HAD SOME ABRASIONS ON HER
FACE.
THEY APPEARED TO BE FRESH
BECAUSE, IN THE VIDEO YOU SEE,
SHE TOUCHES THEM AND SHE SAYS
THEY HURT.
THEY NEVER DOCUMENTED THOSE
ABRASIONS.
BRIAN HAD SOME MARKS ON HIS
ARMS, THEY DID DOCUMENT THEM.
GABBY SAID, OH, IT'S MY FAULT, I
HIT HIM FIRST BUT THEY TOOK THAT
AT FACE VALUE AND MADE HER THE
DOMINANT AGGRESSOR.
IF THERE HAD BEEN ANY ARRESTS,
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN ARRESTED FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE, BRIAN IN
THE BEGINNING SAID I REALLY
DON'T HAVE A CELL PHONE.
BUT LATER ON IN THE OVER
HOUR-LONG PERIOD OF TIME THAT
THE OFFICERS ARE THERE, HE TAKES
OUT A PHONE OUT OF HIS POCKET
AND ACCORDING TO LEGAL FILING
GIVES THEM HIS CELL PHONE
NUMBER.
>> THAT'S SO INTERESTING AND SO
IMPORTANT FOR OTHER CASES, JEAN.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS HERE BECAUSE IT'S A VERY
CREATIVE SUIT.
AND IF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHARGES
HAD BEEN FILED AGAINST BRIAN,
THEY BELIEVE SHE WOULD BE ALIVE
TODAY.
>> JEAN, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT.